- So, who you texting
tonight on the red carpet?
- Me?
- Yeah, who you texting?
There's a phone out, right there.
You hiding it back immediately?
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
I was playing Words with Friends.
- Oh, who are you playing with?
- No, no, no, no, no.
I was playing solitaire.
Who Do Celebs Text On the Red Carpet?
- Who you texting?
- Right now?
- Yeah, who you texting?
- Oh, I mean my phone's over
there but I did just text
Taylor Swift and Jaime King.
We have like a group text
and I sent them all these
like selfies from all angles.
I was like... this is
what's happening right now.
- Have they responded?
- They did respond, they
said very sweet things.
- I can't imagine Taylor
Swift is that sweet
but you know, I believe you.
(Lorde laughing)
- Have you been texting anybody
on this red carpet today?
- Ah, just my dear
friend Robert Downey Jr.
and my close, personal
pal Steven Spielberg.
- Oh, I sent an audio
message saying, "I can't wait
"to see you, girls, I can't
wait to see you, girls!"
Okay, I texted Laura, she
didn't get back to me.
(laughing)
- Laura Prepon does not respond.
- Girl, my phone's not working.
- What happened?
- There's so many people
here, my signal's jammed.
- What are some of the
texts you've been sending
to these bigwigs?
- Which bitches do you have your eye on?
- Who gonna hit it first?
- I'd probably be just
texting like her something.
- Something cute.
- Like where are you?
- Are you here?
Are you nearby?
The security made me move
down to the end of the carpet.
I can't escape!
I'm in the way!
Background, background!
- Background, move
(laughing)
- And has anyone seen my insoles?
- Oh, you're missing your insoles.
- They got away.
- Those are my insoles.
Spielberg is all mad bitches all day.
He's nuts.
- Alright.
- Hey, thanks for stopping by with us.
- Yeah, thanks.
- If you do feel like texting anybody,
she would happily take your number.
- Yeah, I'll take your number.
- You know?
- You'll have to run that by my fiancée.
- Oh, okay.
- What about if I took his number?
I'm way less threatening.
- This is just bad publicity over here.